happy hours c'est le nom du premier
album jazz du pianiste stéphane vinet et
son acolyte le batteur vincent touche
araceli agathon gaumont soir soit vous
êtes avec nous sur le plateau donc c'est
un album de jazz dont le nom n'est pas
dû au hasard mais ont en effet eu les
happy hours sont des rendez vous jazz
hebdomadaires qui ont lieu au prisme à
elancourt alors cela fait cinq ans que
stéphane vinet pianiste et vincent en
touchant batteur joue au p au piano-bar
hall du théâtre
les deux musiciens ont composé un album
de 13 titres essentiellement jazz et
dont voici un extrait meira vescovi
blues r&b
nico qui profite des 10 12
d'où sans doute
nos vies
célia c'est un album à beaucoup d'autres
artistes
oui au fil de leurs rencontres les soit
12 lors de leur soirée 1
de nombreux artistes ont collaboré à cet
album alors comme deux contrebassiste
deux saxophonistes un guitariste et
chanteur un chanteur et une chanteuse
on a essayé de construire le répertoire
de ce disque en fonction des morceaux
qu'on a joué et puis en même temps qui
est qui qui reflétait l'ambiance comment
se sont passées les répétitions en
studio une seule répétition en studio
leur a suffi pour les quelques
arrangements affaires et les voilà
partis
comme lors des happy hours écouter un
autre extrait est suivie et des quelques
mots de vincent touchard le batteur dans
mac os et sodas et far west
on joue des standards ce sont des
reprises et les standards de jazz c'est
le répertoire traditionnel on porte
plainte composition de 2,2 de grands
compositeurs américains
cet album est sorti le 22 janvier sur le
label jazz family il est également
l'album jazz de la semaine sur la radio
fip
merci ces deux-là gaston beau d'avoir
été avec nous quartier